how'd it get started in the makeup
business so I got a great question from
one of my youtube viewers love you guys
Carolyn who wants to start her own
business in makeup I wrote in with this
question
hi mr. Evan my name is Carolyn I'm 18
years old I had this dream of making my
own makeup line I have such a big
passion for makeup and I've loved it
since I was 13 but I get confused
sometimes I don't know where to start
should it be a chemistry major should I
go to school design for makeup industry
I had this dream of making my own line
very different from others I wanted to
be very organic we beneficial to the
user if you could share some tips or
give me advice this would mean a lot to
me thank you PS I'm a recent subscriber
but I love all your videos so Carolyn
welcome aboard welcome to the belief
team it's great to have you on as a
subscriber this is a great question to
answer it I'm going to give you two two
bits of advice the first is is follow
your passion so you know you love makeup
but when you're making your decision
here as to whether you should go be a
chemistry major or the you should Jo go
join a school where you learn about
makeup the answer really depends on what
excites you about makeup right so if you
love how it's made you want to learn how
it's made you want to make your own when
you want to be in the lab you love all
the scientific elements of it then go
major in chemistry you're going to learn
a lot about it it's gonna get you
excited you're gonna love it but if you
love learning about the business side
the marketing the promotion all of the
other stuff then maybe the other school
is gonna be better fit for you I don't
want you to go and spend all this time
you know majoring in chemistry for
example if that's not what is your
passion in the candy in the makeup
business right because you're gonna be
sitting there sitting in class learning
a whole bunch of stuff about chemistry
that's not going to be relevant to the
makeup line thinking man this sucks
right you're gonna have a miserable life
that's not what I want you this is the
anti miserable life strategy okay you've
got to do whatever excites you so think
about why you're starting this again if
it's for the how you make it the
chemistry part of it take the chemistry
if it's the marketing the business side
then go for the other course okay but
you have to listen to your heart and go
for what packing you're passionate about
it's great divert identified what it is
and you've loved make it for the past
five years you have to continue along
that path number two is go get some
experience and what I would encourage
you to do is on top of your education
from from you know books and schools go
get some real-world hands-on experience
it's one of the best things you can do
and I would try to tackle every aspect
of the makeup business as much as you
can so you can learn as much as you can
about the industry so I try to work at a
company that makes makeup the
manufacturer I try to work at our
retailer somebody who is selling the
makeup I would try to work at a
wholesaler who's the bridge between your
manufacturer and the retailer maybe work
at an advertising agency that's selling
makeup I try to get my hands to learn
about all the different aspects of the
makeup field to see what you love right
to see what gets your heart beating what
gets you all excited because that'll
give you the confidence and the
knowledge to go out and do your own
thing and know that you're on the right
path and it looks terrible on your
resume right to do something for three
months and then something else for three
months and something else for three
months it looks terrible right so I
think you like why you bounce it around
so much but your goal here isn't this
soon to be the greatest employee ever
it's to learn the business and learn
what excites you and if you're in a job
doing something that you don't enjoy
then you have to move on and go do
something else and it's okay to explore
and it's okay to bounce around
especially where you are at now in your
life because the worst thing you can do
is go get some job in the makeup field
and then realize that man this is not
what I thought it was this is not where
I want to be and then you don't leave
because that's what most people end up
doing they graduate from school they
take a job on a career track and they
may like it a little bit at the start
but then as they get into it their
interest just tanks and you see them
just living for the weekend they can't
wait til it's time to leave go home
sometime with family and for the weekend
to come that's a miserable life so don't
be afraid to try something
let's get the experience see if you like
it and if you do keep going with it and
if you don't go and find something else
but as especially where you are now with
your point in your life get as much
exposure to the makeup field as possible
from as many different angles and see
what resonates the most see what you you
wake up early to go to that job like I
can't wait to launch this or to do this
task right see if you're dragging your
feet to go to that job you know it's not
gonna be the right fit for you but if
you're excited your heart's beating your
passion is there that's where you want
to spend more time and figuring that out
will give you the advantage so when you
start your business you know where to go
believe thanks for the great question
for those of you watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
let me know what you think by leaving a
comment underneath and if you have a
question for me leave it below make a
video response you want to see more
videos like this click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and I'll see you soon